Speaker 1: I'm going to play a video for you
today. It is a video of a right wing meteorologist
going completely mental on Tucker Carlson.
I thought I was on hallucinogens. I thought
maybe someone slipped acid into my cappuccino or a
flat white. I've been going more in the direction
of the flat white lately. Something about that
foam. But that's really for a different day. I
thought I was on something when I saw this video
because the video doesn't make any sense. A Fox
News propagandist, Tucker Carlson, who does
entertainment. Remember when if when when the
rubber hits the road and Tucker gets sued, lawyers
go, oh, this is not news. This is entertainment.
Okay. He did a segment, an entertainment segment,
I guess, with a meteorologist named Joe Bastardi.
And that's that's really his name. I'm not I know
people will write in and say, David, that's that's
rude. You're being rude by calling him bastard.
No, no. His name is Joe Bastardi. This video
is so unbelievably unhinged, but it's a great
representation of how the right to a great degree.
I was going to say analyzes but there's really
no analysis here. Deals with topics they don't
like. The right gets angry that, for example,
people now believe in climate change and climate
science and bestaev starts rattling off right
wing talking points interspersed with the word
climate change. He throws the word vaccine
and COVID in there as well. I challenge
you to figure out what the hell this guy is
talking about. Okay, let's get into it. I want.
Speaker 3: To know, I've been giving this a lot
of thought today because I had to drive from.
Speaker 1: Oh, guys, he's
been thinking that can't be.
Speaker 3: Good. Iowa City all the way to
Pittsburgh. And when I went by South Bend,
oddly enough, it hit me. There are
three possibilities here, in my opinion,
just looking at this. Okay. First is they've all
got climate vaccines. We don't know about them,
but unlike the COVID vaccine, they actually
work. So whatever they do, they're immune
from it. Okay. That's a possibility.
That's a long shot is sick. The second
talker is that if bad weather stops air travel
and it stops car travel, if you can cause
more bad weather right there, guess what?
Speaker 1: Even Tucker is having trouble
following this or pretending to, because
that's really all he does. At the end of the.
Speaker 3: Day, everybody can't drive. For
instance, next week and the week after,
watch how much bad weather comes into the United
States. It's going to be the coldest, snowiest
period around the Christmas time since 2000.
Speaker 1: So now I think what he's doing
right now is it's going to snow in December. So
climate change couldn't possibly be real. I think
that that's what this part of the diatribe is.
Speaker 3: We're going to see planes and trains
and all these other things shut down. So if you
just dump all. The CO2 in the atmosphere. Your
assumption is, hey, CO2 causes bad weather. If
I can cause more bad weather, then guess what?
Speaker 1: If you're watching, Tucker
isn't frozen. He just looks really
confused. He's in like a confused trance.
Speaker 3: People won't be able to fly,
will have less CO2 emissions. Or the third
possibility, exactly what you said. It's a
phony climate war. It's fraudulent. You could
tell. Back when we talked back in in July,
we were talking about it's going to get
cold early this year across the United
States. That has nothing to do with CO2.
What it has to do is the natural cycles of
the weather. And what's happened is these
people have taken advantage of people who
fall prey to this. And this is what they're
doing. There's no logical reason for it,
except they are trying to establish a caste
system that destroys the greatest experiment.
Speaker 1: In caste system.
Speaker 3: Freedom and individuality, which
is this country right here in the United States.
Speaker 1: Of course. I mean, if you really.
Speaker 2: Believe that carbon was a
pollutant, you would be planting pine
and spruce and hemlock and evergreens across
the country. But they're cutting them down to
make way for highways and dollar stores.
Speaker 1: That's a completely unrelated
issue. And chucker, not pretending to be a tree
saving environmentalist is really the cherry on
top that ran that scrambled mess of what I believe
qualifies as English language words. That's what's
going on in the heads of many of these right
wingers when, you know, when our correspondent
Luke Beasley, the bee's knees or whoever,
they go to the Trump rallies and they talk to
these Trumpists and it's just stuff is coming
out. You hear noise coming out of the mouth,
but it doesn't really make any sense. This is
what's going on in their brain. This is what's
going on in their brain. It's just saying climate
change every few seconds while throwing another
right wing talking points. And this is this guy
is an outspoken climate denier. He's written books
about it. The scientific consensus is completely
at odds with everything that he says. He said the
world is warmer. It was warmer in the thirties
than today, as measured how and in what context
and what does it really matter at the end of the
day? He says that human contributions to carbon
dioxide are so small that they couldn't possibly
have any effect. Science does not agree with that.
It's a complete and total mess. And so this is
sort of like the blind leading the blind. It's the
perfect audience, the Fox News audience. But these
folks are dangerous because next thing you know,
you'll go on the conservative subreddit and people
are repeating the this guy's exact talking points.
So this stuff spreads like a virus. They don't
seem to be inoculated against the disinformation.
And here we are left to pick up the pieces and
try to figure out how we can make some progress
on dealing with this issue. Sad, sad stuff.
Very, very sad stuff. Make sure if you have an
Amazon Prime account that you have subscribed
to Twitch Prime, it's free if you have Amazon
Prime. And when you subscribe to Twitch Prime
at Twitch.tv slash David Pakman, you basically
send us a few dollars that would otherwise go to
Jeff Bezos. That sounds pretty damn good given
that it costs you nothing. Check it out. We're
going to take a quick break and be right back.